l'ordre du jour
déclaration du gouvernement relative à
la stratégie nationale du plan de
déconfinement dans le cadre de la lutte
contre l'épidémie de covile 19 suivies
d'un débat et d'un vote en application
de l'article 51 de la constitution
monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues
la science est ouverte la séance de ce
jour est ouverte ouverte aux espoirs que
nous partageons avec nos compatriotes et
résolument tournée vers des lendemains
heureux que chacun d'entre nous appelle
de ses voeux
mes chers collègues l'heure n'est pas en
ces instants aux considérations
secondaires temps nous sentons au plus
profond de nous-mêmes avec le peuple
français que nous traversons une épreuve
qui marquera l'histoire de notre pays
l'histoire de l'europe et du monde avec
son cortège de peur d'incertitude et de
doute en ces lieux empreints de
l'histoire féconde et tourmentée de
notre démocratie
nous savons tous combien nos valeurs de
liberté d'égalité de fraternité ont pu
être plusieurs fois mise à rude épreuve
cet hémicycle où la nation est
représenté avec eu des guerres des
drames des pandémies des catastrophes
naturelles
autant de moments saisissant qui
obscurcissent l'horizon
parfois cette noirceur color de
nombreuses existence face à la menace
sur noise de virus silencieux qui a déjà
arraché à la vie tant de femmes et
d'hommes de père et de mère deux frères
et deux soeurs d'amis et de camarades le
doute et la peur vient ébranler nos
propre rationalité tandis que
l'optimisme consubstantielle à la vie
conduit à s'accrocher à chaque espérance
naissante dans ce moment où l'impatience
et la traduction du désir de vivre
il nous faut admettre une part
d'ignorance et de tâtonnements il nous
faut reconnaître que les plaies de cette
crise s'annonce profonde et qu'il ne
suffira pas de mots pour les pensées
aujourd'hui monsieur le premier ministre
vous savez que vous ne gouverner pas un
phénomène qui nous domine et nous savons
mes chers collègues que la pandémie est
plus forte que n'importe laquelle de nos
lois nul impuissance à dire cela
seulement la conscience d'être rappelé
au tragique de toute histoire
individuelle ou collective qui rend
dérisoires toute vanité puisse mes chers
collègues s'étaient grandement général
nous apprendre aborder les sujets dans
toutes leurs profondes complexité et non
dans leur apparente simplicité cette
responsabilité nous la devons français
puisque nous sommes la représentation
nationale
mes chers collègues vous n'êtes pas
seulement 75 députés dans cet hémicycle
effectifs exceptionnellement réduit pour
respecter les recommandations sanitaires
et je salue bien sûr tous nos collègues
dont l'absence physique ne doit pas
masquer le travail actif et la présence
à distance vous n'êtes pas seulement 75
députés
vous représentez la république dans sa
riche diversité avec ses sensibilités et
ses conceptions politiques différentes
vous n'êtes pas seulement 75 députés ou
porter l'attenté l'espérance de millions
de français qui nous regardent
aujourd'hui car l'histoire qu'ils nous
convoquent et celle de la vie
quotidienne de chacun et de notre destin
collectif cette responsabilité nous la
devons aussi à tous ceux dont l'énergie
le courage force notre admiration
les soignants les forces de sécurité de
secours les fonctionnaires les paysans
les ouvriers les salariés les parents
les élus de tous les territoires aussi
qui nous rappellent chaque jour que la
france est diverse et que de généreuses
initiatives solidaires fond de la
fraternité un ciment national face à la
tempête et donne corps à ce mot de notre
devise nationale
monsieur le premier ministre vous
témoigner à l'assemblée nationale un
profond respect à n'ayant choisi de vous
exprimer d'abord depuis cette tribune
vous recevrez l' écoute attentive d'une
assemblée habité certes par l'esprit de
concorde qu'impose le contexte national
mais bien sûr aussi dans le différend
ski
fondent notre démocratie même nul doute
que le riche débat qui va s'engager le
vote qui le clôturera permettra à chacun
de s'exprimer et de s'engager devant les
françaises et les français
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
la parole
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés voilà donc le
moment où nous devons dire à la france
comment notre vie va reprendre depuis le
17 mars dernier notre pays vit confiné
qui aurait imaginé il ya seulement trois
mois la place que ce mot à les prendre
dans notre débat public qui aurait pu
envisager une france dans laquelle
subitement les écoles les universités
les cafés les restaurants
une majorité d'entreprises les
bibliothèques les librairies les églises
les temples les synagogues les mosquées
les jardins publics et les plages les
théâtres les stades
tous ces lieux communs pour utiliser une
formule qu'affectionne le président de
l'assemblée nationale aurait été fermé
jamais dans l'histoire de notre pays
nous n'avons connu cette situation ni
pendant les guerres ni pendant
l'occupation ni pendant les précédentes
épidémies
jamais jamais le pays n'avait été
confinés comme il l'est aujourd'hui
et de toute évidence il ne peut l'être
durablement car si le confinement a
constitué une étape nécessaire
il pourrait si elle durait trop
longtemps entraîné des effets délétères
le confinement était un instrument
efficace pour lutter contre le virus
pour contenir la progression de
l'épidémie
pour éviter la saturation de nos
capacités hospitalières et ce faisant
pour protéger les français les plus
fragiles depuis le 14 avril dernier le
nombre de cas de kevin 19 hospitalisés
diminue de plus de trente deux mille
patients hospitalisés les descendue à
environ 28 milles depuis le 8 avril le
nombre de cas de kovy de 19 en
réanimation diminue il dépassait 7100
il est désormais de 4600 la décrue est
engagé elle est régulière lente
j'y reviendrai mais régulière selon une
étude de l'école des hautes études de
santé publique
le confinement aura permis d'éviter au
moins soixante deux mille décès sur un
mois et 105 mille lits de réanimation
aurait manqué en l'absence de
confinement je ne crois pas mesdames et
messieurs les députés que notre pays il
aurait supporté mais un instrument ne
vaut que si ces effets positifs ne sont
pas dans la durée
dépassé par ses conséquences négatives
or nous savons par l'intuition par
l'expérience qu'un confinement prolonger
au delà du strict nécessaire aurait pour
la nation des conséquences gravissimes
nous sentons que l'arrêt prolongé de la
production de pans entiers de notre
économie que la perturbation durable de
la scolarisation d'un grand nombre
d'enfants et d'adolescents que
l'interruption des investissements
publics ou privés que la fermeture
prolongée les frontières que l'extrême
limitation de la liberté d'aller et
venir de se réunir de rentrer visite à
ses proches à ses parents présenterait
pour le pays
non pas seulement l'inconvénient pénible
du confinement
mais en vérité celui bien plus terrible
du risque de l'écroulement écroulement
je n'emploie pas ce terme au hasard
mesdames et messieurs les députés
on me reproche bien plus souvent la
litote que l'exagération
il nous faut donc progressivement
prudemment mais aussi résolument
procéder à un déconfinement aussi
attendu que risquée et redouté
l'objectif du gouvernement est de
présenter à l'assemblée nationale et
grâce à elle aux français notre
stratégie nationale c'est à dire les
buts que nous recherchons et la façon
dont nous allons procéder pour les
atteindre
à compter du 11 mai prochain toute
stratégie repose sur des constats le
premier d'entre eux et médicales il
tient en quelques mots simples que tous
les français doivent avoir en tête
nous allons devoir vivre avec le virus
dès lors qu aucun vaccin n'est
disponible à court terme qu aucun
traitement n'a à ce jour démontré son
efficacité et que nous sommes loin
d'avoir atteint la fameuse immunité de
groupe
le virus va continuer à circuler parmi
nous ce n'est pas réjouissant mais c'est
un fait on peut espérer que le virus
disparaisse de lui même les spécialistes
des épidémies en tout cas certains
s'accordent pour reconnaître que cela
arrive que les épidémies s'arrête
parfois sans qu'on sache très bien
pourquoi on peut espérer que
l'incroyable efforts de recherche
engagés dans le monde entier permettra
de trouver sous peu un traitement et
d'ici 12 à 24 mois
un vaccin qui renverrait ce virus au
rang des questions de santé résolu par
l'intelligence et la technologie humaine
on peut tout à fait espérer tout cela
mais fonder une politique publique est
organisée la vie des français autour d'
hypothèse aussi incertaine n'est pas
envisageable
il nous faut donc apprendre à vivre avec
le co vie de 19 et apprendre à nous en
protéger voilà la première contrainte et
voilà le premier axe de notre stratégie
le deuxième constat est à la fois
médicale et politique
il tient au risque de voir partir les
peelings la décision de confiner notre
pays a permis de ralentir la circulation
du virus
elle a permis que jamais nos services de
réanimation ou de soins intensifs ne
soit saturé au point qu'il n'aurait pu
admettre de nouveaux patients elle a
permis à l'engagement des soignants à
l'imagination des équipes hospitalières
à l'organisation logistique des soins de
tenir en dépit d'une pression
considérable jamais vu mais de tenir et
je veux le dire une nouvelle fois ici
notre système hospitalier a tenu mais il
a tenu au prix d'une fatigue bien
compréhensible des femmes et des hommes
au prix d'une consommation de
médicaments de réanimation de
consommables jamais constaté non plus au
prix d'une déprogrammation des
opérations chirurgicales non nécessaires
à court terme mais qui finiront bien par
lettre le risque d'une seconde vague qui
viendrait frapper un tissu hospitalier
fragilisées qui imposerait un recond
finement lequel redresse les efforts et
les sacrifices consentis au cours de ces
huit semaines est un risque sérieux
un risque qu'il faut prendre au sérieux
ce risque impose de procéder avec
prudence
progressivement sûrement en reprenant
notre vie selon des modalités qui
permettent
semaine après semaine de vérifier que
nous maîtrisons le rythme de circulation
du virus
le deuxième axe de notre stratégie sera
donc la progressivité
le troisième élément à prendre en compte
et géographique
il tient là aussi en quelques mots la
circulation du virus n'est pas uniforme
dans le pays certaines parties ont été
durement touchés certains territoires
connaissent encore aujourd'hui après six
semaines de confinement un nombre
quotidien significatif de nouveaux cas
mais dans d'autres
le virus est quasiment absent
cette circulation hétérogène du virus
créé de fait des différences entre les
territoires
pour tous ceux qui comme moi croient au
bon sens il n'est pas inutile il est
même très nécessaire de prendre en
compte ces différences dans la façon
dont le déconfinement doit être organisé
à la fois pour ne pas appliquer le même
schéma dans des endroits où la situation
n'est objectivement pas la même mais
aussi pour laisser aux autorités locales
notamment au maire et au préfet la
possibilité d'adapter la stratégie
nationale en fonction des circonstances
c'est d'ailleurs pour cela qu'avec le
président de la république nous avons
décidé de dire rapidement quel était
notre stratégie nationale afin qu'au
plus tôt ceux qui vont participer à sa
mise en oeuvre puissent prendre leurs
dispositions avec plusieurs membres du
gouvernement
avec le coordonnateur interministériel
jean castex
je rencontrerai dès demain les
associations d'élus locaux et les
préfets puis jeudi les partenaires
sociaux pour engager ce travail de
concertation et d'adaptation du plan aux
réalités de terrain
vivant avec le virus agir
progressivement adaptées localement
voilà les trois principes de notre
stratégie nationale à partir du 11 mai
sa mise en oeuvre va reposer sur le
triptyque protéger tester isolé protéger
d'abord protéger cet évident et d'être
éviter d'être infecté par le virus ou
d'infecter les autres les médecins nous
disent que la contagiosité de la maladie
apparaît deux jours avant les premiers
symptômes et disparaît plusieurs jours
après ils disent également qu'une
proportion non négligeable de porteurs
du virus ne déclenche aucun symptôme et
ne savent pas au fond qu ils peuvent
transmettre le virus
dès lors il est impératif que chacun
puisse adopter les comportements qui
permettent d'éviter la contamination
à partir du moment où nous ne serons
plus en situation de confinement où les
occasions de contacts augmenteront à
nouveau il faudra les limiter mais elles
font plus importante qu'aujourd'hui le
respect des gestes barrières et des
mesures de distanciation social
distanciation physique préférons ce
terme mais prendra encore plus
d'importance
ces gestes barrières tout le monde les
connaît désormais c'est notamment là dix
stations la distanciation physique et le
lavage régulier des mains
à cela il conviendra d'ajouter et je dis
bien d'ajouter le port du masque quand
certaines situations et je souhaite
revenir précisément sur ce sujet car
cette question des masques a suscité
l'incompréhension et la colère de
nombreux français pourquoi n'y avait-il
pas pour tout le monde
fallait-il emporté où les trouver
lorsque la crise a commencé nous
disposions d'un stocks importants de
masques chirurgicaux important au sens
où ils permettaient de répondre à plus
de 20 semaines de consommation normale
des services hospitaliers la production
nationale était inférieure à la
combattre à la consommation normale mais
complété par des importations régulière
avec l'apparition de l'épidémie en chine
puis sont arrivés en italie deux
éléments sont apparus clairement
l'importation est momentanément devenu
impossible et la consommation a
considérablement augmenté dans des
proportions incroyablement supérieur à
la normale comme tous les pays européens
comme les états unis d'amérique la
france a dû gérer un risque de pénurie
de masques
trois décisions ont donc été prises
d'abord d'augmenter la production
nationale de masques chirurgicaux autant
que faire se peut ce n'est pas simple
mais nous sommes en train d'y parvenir
en doublant d'abord et en atteignant
bientôt cinq fois sa production initiale
ensuite réserver le stock existant aux
soignants hospitalier pour garantir la
fourniture de ces masques à ceux qui en
première ligne aurait à soigner les
malades
il est arrivé mesdames et messieurs les
députés que nous doutions de notre
capacité à garantir cet
approvisionnement dans la durée réservez
les masques aux soignants c'était
mécaniquement refusé de les distribuer à
d'autres c'est un choix difficile
c'est un choix contesté c'est un fois
que j'ai estimé nécessaire
enfin nous avons lancé la production de
masque en tissu pour compléter l'offre
et ne pas dépendre des importations dont
nous ne savions pas si elles pourraient
reprendre
et si oui pour combien de temps les
scientifiques eux mêmes ont évolué au
début beaucoup nous disait que le port
du masque en population générale n'était
pas nécessaire que le risque du mauvais
usage étaient supérieurs aux avantages
espérés et nous l'avons répété et je les
dis ils nous disent aujourd'hui
parfois les mêmes qu'il est préférable
dans de nombreux dans de nombreuses
circonstances de porter un masque plutôt
que de ne pas en porter et il me revient
donc de le dire et de faire en sorte que
cela soit possible
pendant la phase de pénurie nous avons
utilisé l'outil des réquisitions qui a
été fort utile depuis plusieurs semaines
maintenant
depuis que nous sommes rassurés sur
notre capacité à servir les soignants au
sens large en masque
nous incitons l'ensemble des acteurs à
se procurer des masques et les données
des douanes le montre d'ailleurs assez
clairement il rentre bien plus de
masques dans le pays que le gouvernement
n'ont aps le mans et croyez moi ils en
commande puisque nous recevons près de
100 millions de masques chirurgicaux par
semaine désormais est que nous recevrons
près de 20 millions de masques grand
public lavable à compter du mois de mai
nous avons incité les entreprises les
collectivités à se procurer également
des masques certaines n'ont pas attendu
que nous les incitons nous soutiendront
financièrement les collectivités locales
qui a sept à compter de ce jour des
masques grand public en prenant en
charge 50 % du coût des masques dans les
limites d'un prix de référence et nous
avons réouvert récemment vous l'avez
probablement remarqué les marchands de
tissus et les ateliers de couture et
diffuser des guides pratiques de
confection de masques afin que chacun se
mobilise pour en produire grâce à la
mobilisation de tous il y aura donc
assez de masques dans le pays pour faire
face aux besoins à partir du 11 mai mais
l'enjeu la responsabilité des pouvoirs
publics
notre responsabilité collective c'est
d'arriver dans les prochaines semaines a
organisé cet effort pour éviter que
certains entre guillemets en ait trop
quand d'autres
on en aurait pas progressivement nous
parviendrons à une situation classique
où les français pourront sans risque de
pénurie se procurer des masques grand
public dans tous les commerces
en attendant il faut que l'état les
collectivités territoriales les
entreprises
l'initiative privée soient
complémentaires et non concurrents le
président de la république l'a dit nous
nous appuierons sur les maires et les
préfets avec le concours de tous
j'invite toutes les entreprises quand
leurs moyens le permettent a veillé à
équiper leurs salariés
c'est une condition elles le savent
elles le disent de la reprise les
régions et l'état mettra en place un
appui aux tpe et aux travailleurs
indépendants au delà des initiatives
déjà prises par un certain nombre de
branches ou d'organisations
professionnelles une plateforme de
e-commerce sera mise en place par la
poste à compter du 30 avril et
distribuera à ceux qui en ont besoin
chaque semaine plusieurs millions de
masques grand public
l'état et les collectivités locales
assureront la protection de leur
personnel en particulier ceux qui sont
en contact avec le public
les préfets et disposeront d'une
enveloppe locales pour soutenir avec les
collectivités territoriales les plus
petites collectivités
les personnels de l'éducation et les
élèves des collèges recevront également
des masques les pharmacies et la grande
distribution seront invités à vendre
dans des conduites dans des conditions
que nous définirons avec eux pour éviter
les phénomènes de pénurie des masques
jetables ou la 20 les particuliers sont
bien sûr invités je les dis à se
confectionner eux-mêmes des masques dans
les conditions recommandées par l'afnor
et par la nsf
enfin nous réserveront une enveloppe
hebdomadaire de 5 millions de masques
lavables pour que les préfets organise
avec les maires et les présidents de
conseils départementaux la distribution
de masques à nos concitoyens qui se
trouvent dans le plus grand état de
précarité via les ccas et les acteurs
associatifs protéger donc tester ensuite
là encore les recommandations
scientifiques ont évolué et après tout
sans doute est ce normal
face à un virus inconnu cette crise
sanitaire renvoi décidément tout le
monde
à devoir d'humilité la doctrine initial
consistait dans ce que nous appelions la
phase 1 a testé au maximum une
d'ailleurs nous avons beaucoup testé en
phase 1
lorsqu'un cas est apparu aux contamines
montjoie et qu'il a fallu le
circonscrire
nous avons testé massivement tous ceux
qui s'était approché de près ou de loin
des malades identifiées mais la doctrine
voulait qu'une fois l'épidémie passer en
phase 3 on ne testent plus que les
malades hospitalisés pour suspicion de
coheed les soignants symptomatique et
les premiers cas dans les établissements
accueillant des publics fragiles c'est
ce que nous avons fait les temps ont
changé la doctrine de l'om associé à la
sortie du confinement
nous serons en capacité de massifier nos
tests nous nous sommes fixé l'objectif
de réaliser au moins 700 mille tests
virologiques par semaine au 11 mai
pourquoi cette envie parce que le
conseil scientifique nous dit que parce
que le conseil scientifique nous dit à
ce stade que les modèles
épidémiologiques prévoit entre 1000 et
3000 cas nouveaux chaque jour à partir
du 11 mai parce qu'à chaque cas nouveau
correspondra en moyenne le test d'au
moins 20 à 25 personnes l'ayant croisé
dans les jours précédents 3000 x 25 x 7
cela donne 525 milles test par semaine
sept cent mille nous donne la marge qui
nous permettra en plus des tests des
chaînes de contamination que je viens de
décrire de mettre en oeuvre des
campagnes de dépistage comme nous
l'avons déjà engagés pour les ehpad
notamment pour atteindre cette cible
nous avons fait sauter les verrous qui
empêchait la participation des
laboratoires de recherche et des
laboratoires vétérinaires à cet effort
collectif
la capacité à faire sauter ces verrous
sur le terrain pas seulement dans les
discours est un exercice qui incite là
aussi je peux vous le dire à une grande
humilité
nous avons engagé la mobilisation
conjointe des laboratoires publics et
privés qui peuvent aujourd'hui montée en
charge très rapidement en termes de
capacité cette mobilisation permettra de
garantir sur tout le territoire
un accès de proximité aux prélèvements
nous allons enfin faire passer à 100% la
prise en charge de cette de ces tests
pardon par l'assurance maladie
en un mot tout doit être fait pour
rendre la réalisation du test facile et
rapide dès lors qu'une personne n'aura
été testée positive nous engagerons un
travail d'identification et le test de
tous ceux symptomatique ou non qui
auront eu un contact rapproché avec elle
tous ces cas contacts seront testés et
seront invités à s'isoler
compte tenu des incertitudes sur la
durée d'incubation cette règle
cette règle est assez simple à formuler
mais elle exige pour être appliquée de
façon systématique partout en france des
moyens considérables
nous ne pourrons réussir que grâce à la
mobilisation des professionnels de santé
libéraux notamment aux médecins
généralistes et infirmiers libéraux
ils constitueront d'une certaine manière
la première ligne dans cette recherche
des cas contacter pour tout ce qui
concerne la cellule familiale
je sais qu'ils peuvent se mobiliser pour
cette mission et nous les accompagnerons
pour cela on appuie les équipes de
l'assurance-maladie assureront la
démultiplication de cette démarche
d'identification des cas contacts au
delà de la cellule familiale dans chaque
département nous constituerons des
brigades chargées de remonter la liste
des cas contacts de les appeler de les
inviter à se faire tester en leur
indiquant à quel endroit ils doivent se
rendre
puis à vérifier que ces tests ont bien
eu lieu et que leurs résultats donnent
lieu à l'application correcte de la
doctrine nationale protéger d'abord
tester ensuite est isolé enfin
l'objectif final de cette politique
ambitieuse de tests c'est de permettre
d'isoler au plus vite les porteurs du
virus afin de casser les chaînes de
transmission l'isolément mesdames et
messieurs les députés des états une
punition musulman n'est pas une sanction
isolement c'est une mesure de précaution
collective c'est une mise à l'abri
isolement doit donc
être expliquée consentis et accompagner
notre politique repose à cet égard sur
la responsabilité individuelle et la
conscience que chacun doit avoir de ses
devoirs à l'égard des autres nous
prévoirons des dispositifs de contrôle
s'il devait être nécessaire mais notre
objectif est de nous reposer largement
sur le civisme de chacun et on observe
d'ailleurs les médecins le disent ce
qu'ils ont eu à gérer des épidémies ne
disent que la conscience individuelle le
respect civique des règles lorsque l'on
est déclaré positif ou malades et
souvent quasiment absolu il reviendra au
préfet et aux collectivités
territoriales de définir ensemble avec
les acteurs associatifs les
professionnels de santé les acteurs de
la prise en charge à domicile le plan
d'accompagnement des personnes placées
dans cette forme d'isolement
nous laisserons le choix à la personne
testée positive de s'isoler chez elle ce
qui entraînera le confinement de tous le
foyers pendant 14 jours pour des raisons
évidentes ou bien de s'isoler dans un
lieu mis à sa disposition notamment dans
des hôtels réquisitionné un mot encore
sur ce sujet mais un mot important
pourrons-nous ou devrons-nous afin
d'être plus efficaces nous appuyer sur
les ressources extraordinaires des
outils numériques
un consortium européen a lancé un
travail devant permettre la création de
l'application stop que vides dont
l'utilité ne peut s'envisager que de
façon complémentaire à ce que je viens
de décrire complémentaires parce que les
enquêtes sanitaires que j'ai décrite
qu'elle soit physique ou téléphonique
sont vitales mais présente une faiblesse
elle se heurte parfois dans les centres
urbains à l'impossibilité de
reconstituer les scènes de transmission
dans les lieux les plus denses et
notamment dans les transports en commun
difficile de prévenir
celui qui a partagé votre rame de métro
à 7h46 sur la ligne 12
vous ne le connaissez pas il ne vous
connais pas et la ratp ne connais ni
l'un ni l'autre
c'est l'objet du projet stop loving qui
permettrait aux personnes qui ont croisé
une personne testée positive d'intégrer
un parcours sanitaires sans bien entendu
avoir aucune information sur l'identité
de la personne croisée un grand nombre
de responsables politiques sur tous les
bancs le président de l'assemblée
nationale lui même ont fait part de
leurs interrogations sur ce type
d'instrument sur les questions que son
utilisation ne manquerait pas de poser
en termes de libertés publiques et de
libertés individuelles
ces questions j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
le dire
me paraissent fondées elles doivent être
posées elles doivent être débattues j'ai
même le sentiment qu'elles doivent faire
l'objet d'un vote pour leur compte tenu
des incertitudes sur cette application
je serais bien en peine de vous dire si
elle fonctionne et comment elle
fonctionnera précisément je ne doute pas
que les ingénieurs travailleront
d'arrache-pied
ils réussiront à faire fonctionner ce
projet mais dès lors que ce n'est pas le
cas il me semble pour tout vous dire
mesdames et messieurs les députés que le
débat est un peu prématuré mais je
confirme mon engagement lorsque
l'application en cours de développement
fonctionnera et avant sa mise en oeuvre
nous organiserons un débat spécifique
suivi d'un vote spécifique pour procéder
aux déconfinement nous allons donc
partout protège et testé est isolé et
comme je vous l'indiquais nous allons
procéder progressivement et en
différenciant en fonction des
territoires progressivement d'abord
progressivement parce qu'il ne faut pas
laisser repartir l'épidémie parce que
nous voulons éviter une deuxième vague
parce que nous tous ici préférons éviter
qu'après le confinement
puis le déconfinement nous ayons à rome
à connaître d'un reconfirme en
généraliser
progressivement cela veut dire que nous
préparons le 11 mai en surveillant tous
les indicateurs pour vérifier
département par département que nous
pouvons effectivement lancé les
opérations à cette date un exemple pour
illustrer ma prudence
j'ai indiqué que nous fondions notre
stratégie de test sur une hypothèse de
3000 cas nouveau par jour autour du 11
mai si le confinement se relâchait d'ici
là si allah proche du 11 mai disons
jeudi 7 mai il apparaissait que le
nombre de nouveaux cas journalier
n'était pas dans la fourchette prévue
que nous ne parvenions pas à casser les
trop nombreuses chaînes de contamination
alors nous devrions en tirer les
conséquences
je le dis aux français si les
indicateurs ne sont pas au rendez vous
nous ne déconfinement pas le 11 mai où
nous le ferons plus strictement je
préférerais croyez moi que les
modélisateurs les épidémiologistes
puisse nous dire que leurs hypothèses de
3000 cas par jour au 11 mai se vérifie
mais si tel n'est pas le cas je le dirai
avec autant de clarté qu'il faudra hier
j'ai reçu du directeur général de la
santé des modélisations moins favorable
peut-être parce que les comportements se
relâche un peu peut-être parce que la
baisse des hospitalisations être lente
peut-être aussi parce que les hypothèses
sur lesquelles sont fondées ces
modélisations ne vont pas s'avérer exact
je le dis ici devant la représentation
nationale avec solennité
ces incertitudes doivent inciter à tous
les français pardon tous les français à
la plus grande discipline d'ici au 11
mai et à lutter contre les risques de
relâchement que nous sentons parfois
monter dans le pays
si tout est prêt comme nous le pensons
le 11 mai alors commencera une phase qui
durera jusqu'au 2 juin
elle permettra de vérifier que les
mesures mises en oeuvre permettent de
maîtriser l'épidémie et d'apprécier
en fonction de ces évolutions les
mesures à prendre pour la phase suivante
qui débutera le 2 juin et qui ira
jusqu'à l'été ces femmes et notamment
que nous statuerons sur la réouverture
des cafés et des restaurants
c'est donc en gravissant démarche de
trois semaines que nous allons avancer
en étant attentif à l'effet de nos
décisions et aux comportements de nos
concitoyens la progressivité
s'accompagne d'une différenciation selon
les territoires
je les dis tous les territoires n'ont
pas été touchés de la même manière par
l'épidémie et nous espérons tous que le
11 mai si le virus continue à circuler
dans certains départements sa présence
sera très faible voire nul
dans d'autres il est donc logique que
tout en gardant la plus extrême prudence
nous proposions un cadre de
déconfinement adapté aux réalités
locales de l'hexagone comme de
l'outre-mer la direction générale de la
santé et santé publique france ont
établi trois ensemble de critères
permettant d'identifier les départements
où le déconfinement doit prendre une
forme plus stricte soit que le taux de
cas nouveaux dans la population sur une
période de sept jours reste élevé ce qui
montrerait que la circulation du virus
reste active soit c'est le deuxième
ensemble de critères que les capacités
hospitalières régional en réanimation
reste tendue soit c'est le troisième
ensemble de critères que le système
local de test et de détection des
chaînes de contamination ne soit pas
suffisamment prêt ces indicateurs leurs
lectures seront cristalliser le 7 mai
afin de déterminer quel département
bascule le 11 mai dans la catégorie
disons rouge circulation est levé vers
circulation limitée
à compter de jeudi le jeudi le directeur
général de la santé présentera tous les
soirs la carte avec les résultats
département par département cette carte
guidera ainsi chaque département dans la
préparation du 11 mai en rappelant
l'objectif d'un confinement strict pour
faire baisser la circulation du virus
mais aussi le besoin de remettre sur
pied le système hospitalier et de mettre
en place un système de test de détection
des cas contactez efficace je vous ai
présenté les constats sur lesquels nous
avons bâti la stratégie nationale de
déconfinement puis ces instruments de
santé publique
je souhaite désormais vous présenter
comment va s'organiser la vie
quotidienne des français à partir du 11
notre stratégie nationale de
déconfinement fixe les règles
applicables pour quelques enjeux
prioritaires l'école les entreprises les
commerces les transports la vie
collective où la vie sociale
commençons par l'école le président de
la république l'a rappelé le retour de
nos enfants sur le chemin des écoles est
un impératif pédagogique un impératif de
justice sociale en particulier pour ceux
qui peuvent difficilement suivre
l'enseignement à distance
ce retour nous voulons le concilier avec
la préservation de nos objectifs de
santé publique
pour ce faire nous proposons une
réouverture très progressive des
maternelle et de l'école élémentaire à
compter du 11 mai partout sur le
territoire et sur la base du volontariat
dans un deuxième temps à compter du 18
mai mais seulement dans les départements
où la circulation du virus est très
faible
nous pourrons envisager d'ouvrir les
collèges en commençant par les classes
de 6e et de 5e nous déciderons fin mais
si nous pouvons réouvrir les lycées en
commençant par les lycées professionnels
du jeu cette décision n'a pas été prise
à la légère
nous avons consulté nous avons pesé le
pour et le contre
nous avons étudié ce que font les autres
pays mais la réouverture des écoles est
nécessaire pour garantir la réussite
éducative des élèves notamment les plus
vulnérables d'entre eux dont la
scolarité souple souffre terriblement du
confinement les classes rouvriront dans
des conditions sanitaires strictes pas
plus de 15 élèves par classe une vie
scolaire organisée autour du respect des
règles barrière de mesures d'hygiène
strictes et de la distribution de gel
hydroalcoolique tous les enseignants et
encadrants des établissements scolaires
recevront des masques qu'ils devront
porter quand ils ne pourront respecter
les règles de distanciation sur la
question des masques pour les enfants
les avis scientifiques nous ont conduits
aux décisions suivantes
le port du masque est prohibé pour les
enfants en maternelle il n'est pas
recommandé
compte tenu des risques de mauvais usage
à l'école élémentaire mais l'éducation
nationale mettra des masques pédiatrique
à disposition des directeurs d'école
pour les cas particuliers par exemple si
un enfant présentait au cours d'une
journée des symptômes le temps que ses
parents viennent le récupérer
enfin nous fournirons des masques aux
collégiens qui peuvent emporter et qui
n'auraient pas réussi à se procurer le
port du masque pour les collégiens étant
obligatoire un intense travail de
préparation doit avoir doit avoir lieu
dans chaque académie afin que nous
puissions préparer cette rentrée
évidemment très particulière les enfants
devront pouvoir suivre une scolarité
soit au sein de leur établissement
scolaire dans la limite maximale de 15
élèves par classe sur les dix soit chez
eux avec un enseignement à distance qui
restera gratuit bien et bien entendu
soit en étude
si les locaux scolaires le permettent ou
dans des locaux périscolaires mis à la
disposition par les collectivités
territoriales si elles le souhaitent
pour des activités
sport santé de culture ou de civisme
j'ai admiré la mobilisation de
l'éducation nationale pendant le
confinement le dévouement de milliers
d'enseignants qui se sont mobilisés pour
accueillir les enfants de soignants qui
resteront accueilli bien entendu dans
les temps qui viennent
l'ingéniosité de tous ceux qui se sont
réinventés pour offrir à leurs élèves
des modalités original d'enseignement à
distance et nous avons tous j'en suis
sûr autour de nous des exemples
extraordinaire d'inventivité
d'engagement d'imagination pour que le
lien essentiel entre le maître et son
élève demeure alors même que la période
de confinement était en vigueur
je veux laisser le maximum de souplesse
aux terrains en la matière et je sais
que c'est ainsi que les directeurs
d'école les parents d'élèves les
collectivités locales trouverons
ensemble avec pragmatisme les meilleures
solutions
je leur dis que nous les soutiendrons et
que je leur fais confiance
les crèches seront règle également
réouverte l'accueil par groupe de 10
enfants maximum sera possible avec la
possibilité d'accueillir plusieurs
groupes de dix enfants
si l'espace le permet et si les
conditions sont réunies pour que les
groupes ne se croisent pas cette
réduction des capacités posera au moins
dans un premier temps la question des
priorités d'accueil les crèches
accueillent déjà les enfants selon des
critères économiques et sociaux et il
n'appartient pas à l'état de définir ces
critères à la place les gestionnaires il
me semble néanmoins que l'impossibilité
de télétravail pour un couple d'actifs
ou les difficultés rencontrées par les
familles monoparentales devront être
prises en compte dans ces critères les
enfants des soignants et des professeurs
devraient également à mon avis être
prioritaire
le port du masque grand public sera
obligatoire pour les professionnels de
la petite enfance puisque les règles de
distanciation physique ne peuvent pas y
être appliquée bien sûr bien sûr il n'y
aura pas de port du masque pour les
enfants de moins de 3 ans le
déconfinement doit aussi permettre la
reprise de la vie économique
pour cela il faut réorganiser la vie au
travail
le télétravail doit être maintenue
partout où c'est possible
au moins dans les trois prochaines
semaines je le demande avec insistance
aux entreprises nous en avons mesuré
depuis la mi mars le déploiement massif
personne n'en ignore les contraintes
mais celui ci doit se poursuivre pour
limiter le recours aux transports
publics pour limiter plus globalement
les contacts il n'ya pas sur ce sujet un
avant et un après 11 mai pour les
personnes qui ne pourront pas
télétravail et la pratique des horaires
décalés dans l'entreprise doit être
encouragée elle permettra l'étalement
des flux de salariés dans les transports
et diminuera la présence simultanée des
salariés dans un même espace de travail
s'agissant des conditions de travail
nous devons amplifier la démarche
engagée par les fédérations
professionnelles ministère du travail
pour réaliser les guides et les fiches
métiers qui accompagnent les
réorganisations nécessaires au sein des
entreprises
trente trois guides sont aujourd'hui
disponibles il faut environ 60 il en
faut environ 60 pour couvrir tous les
secteurs j'ai demandé à muriel pénicaud
madame le ministre du travail qu'il soit
prêt pour le 11 mai cette démarche est
intéressante parce qu'elle est très
concrète et qu'elle associe les
partenaires sociaux elle doit se
concrétiser dans chaque entreprise sous
la forme de nouveau plan d'organisation
du travail avec une attention
particulière aux emplois du temps aux
gestes barrière à l'aménagement des
espaces de travail
le port du masque devra être mis en
oeuvre dès lors que les règles de
distanciation physique ne peuvent pas
être garantie dans l'organisation du
travail
j'échangerais jeudi avec les syndicats
de salariés les représentants des
employeurs sur ces sujets
le dialogue social à tous les niveaux
doivent être mobilisées pour permettre
le retour au travail dans un cadre qui
garantit évidemment la santé et la
sécurité des salariés c'est une
condition impérative
nous échangerons également sur les
mesures d'accompagnement des entreprises
qui font face à des difficultés
le dispositif d'activité partielle qui
est un des plus généreux d'europe
restera en place jusqu'au 1er juin il
nous faudra ensuite d'adapter
progressivement afin d'accompagner la
reprise d'activité si l'épidémie est
maîtrisé bien sûr nous continuerons à
protéger les personnes vulnérables et
les secteurs professionnels qui
demeureraient fermés les commerces
ouvriront également à compter du 11 mai
aujourd'hui seuls certains commerces
essentielles sont ouverts tous sauf les
cafés restaurants pourront ouvrir à
compter du 11 mai les marchés pour
lesquels l'interdiction est aujourd'hui
la règle et l'autorisation l'exception
seront en général autorisé sauf si les
maires ou les préfets estiment qu'ils ne
peuvent être organisées dans des
conditions qui permettent de respecter
et gestes barrières et la distanciation
physique car si les commerces vont
rouvrir
chacun d'entre eux devra respecter un
cahier des charges strict limitant le
nombre de personnes présentes en même
temps dans le magasin en organisant les
flux afin de faire respecter la règle de
la distance minimale d'un mètre par
personne sans contact autour d'elle il
devra bien évidemment veiller à la
protection de son personnel
s'agissant du port du masque le port du
masque grand public sera recommandée
pour les personnels et les clients
lorsque les mesures de distanciation
physique ne peuvent être garantis un
commerçant pourra subordonnés l'accès de
son magasin au port du masque j'ajoute
enfin que l'ouverture des commerces
comprendra une exception pour les
centres commerciaux qui ont une zone de
chalandise qui va au delà du bassin de
vie et donc qui génère des déplacements
et des contacts que nous ne voulons pas
encourager les préfets pourront décider
de ne pas laisser ouvrir au delà
défection alimentaire déjà ouvertes
les centres commerciaux de plus de 40
mille mètres carrés qui risque de
susciter de tels mouvements de
population enfin je les dis nous
prendrons une décision sur les bars
cafés et restaurants fin mai pour
décider s'ils peuvent ouvrir après le de
jeu les décisions relatives au transport
sont particulièrement ardue les
transports sont pour une bonne part un
dispositif clé pour la reprise
économique
mais le respect de la distanciation
physique les des gestes barrières
il est particulièrement difficile je
mesure la préhension bon nombre de nos
concitoyens avant de prendre un métro un
train un bus un tramway lesquels sont
parfois fort dense et m'en occuper nous
allons prendre deux séries de décision
d'abord remonter au maximum l'offre de
transports urbains 70% de l'offre de la
ratp sera disponible le 11 mai et nous
devons remonter rapidement à l'offre
nominal ensuite faire baisser la demande
en favorisant le télétravail je les dis
en étalant les horaires je les dis en
demandant aux français de considérer que
les transports aux heures de pointe
doivent être réservées à ceux qui
travaillent le souhaite que dans chaque
région dans chaque agglomération une
concertation s'engage très rapidement
entre les autorités organisatrices de
transport les usagers les opérateurs de
transport pour arrêter les conditions de
mise en oeuvre précise de ses objectifs
l'état y apportera bien sûr son concours
s'il faut organiser les flux réserver
les transports à certaines heures à
certaines populations
nous accompagnerons les autorités
organisatrices de transport nous
essayons d'y arriver ensemble mais il
est certain que les trois semaines à
venir seront difficiles et que nous
devons rester vigilants
le port du masque sera rendue
obligatoire dans tous les transports
mettra ou comme bus et les opérateurs
devront au moins pour les trois semaines
à venir
s'organiser pour permettre même dans le
métro de respecter les gestes barrière
cela veut dire par exemple que la
capacité du métro parisien sera réduite
par rapport au nominal et drastiquement
réduites par rapport à sa capacité
normale qu'il faudra par exemple
condamné un siège sur deux favorisé par
des marquages au sol la bonne
répartition sur les quais se préparer à
limiter les flux en cas d'affluence les
bus scolaires pourront circuler mais
avec la même règle du 1 sur 2 avec
l'obligation de port du masque pour les
chauffeurs et pour les écoliers à partir
du collège le port du masque sera
également obligatoire dans les taxis et
les vtc qui ne disposent pas du système
de protection en plexiglas
s'agissant des déplacements inter
régionaux ou interdépartementaux notre
logique sera inverse
nous voulons réduire ses déplacements au
seul motif professionnels ou familiaux
impérieux pour des raisons évidentes de
limitation de la circulation du virus et
donc nous allons continuer à réduire
l'offre a exigé une réservation
obligatoire dans tous les trains tgv ou
non à décourager les déplacements entre
départements le jeudi de l'ascension
sera bien férié mais je dis clairement
aux français que ce n'est pas le moment
de quitter son département pour partir
en vigueur
enfin le déconfinement c'est le retour
de la vie sociale la patience de nos
concitoyens à retrouver une vie sociale
je crois que nous la partageons tous
j'ai d'abord une pensée pour tous nos
aînés qui au delà du confinement
subissent la solitude à domicile et
parfois l'isolément dans les ehpad privé
pendant de longues semaines de toute
visite de leurs enfants et de leurs
petits enfants
comme vous le savez nous demanderons à
nos aînés de continuer à se protéger il
faut qu'ils respectent des règles
similaires à la période de confinement
en se protégeant en limitant leurs
contacts et donc leur sortie tout cela
sur le principe de confiance et de
responsabilité comme l'a annoncé le
président de la république il n'y aura
pas de contrôle pas d'attestation de
sortie pour les plus âgés d'entre nous
mais je demande aux personnes les plus
âgées les plus fragiles de la patience
les visites privées quand elles
reprennent doivent être entourés de
précaution comme les sorties en vous
protégeant vous protéger le système
hospitalier et vous protéger les plus
fragiles d'entre nous la vie sociale va
reprendre donc mais là encore
progressivement je voudrais d'abord
commencé par dire ce qu'il sera à
nouveau possible de faire il sera à
nouveau possible de circuler librement
sans attestation sauf comme je les dis
pour les déplacements à plus de 100 km
du domicile qui ne seront possibles que
pour un motif impérieux familiales ou
professionnelles
il sera possible les beaux jours et dans
de pratiquer une activité sportive
individuelle en plein air en dépassant
évidemment la barrière actuelle du
kilomètre et en respectant les règles de
distanciation physique il ne sera
possible ni de pratiquer du sport dans
des lieux couverts ni des sports
collectifs ni des sports de contact
les parcs et jardins si essentiel l
équilibre de vie en ville ne pourront
couvrir que dans les départements où le
virus ne circule pas de façon active les
fameux département vert par mesure de
précaution les plages resteront
inaccessibles au public au moins
jusqu'au 1er juin s'agissant des
activités culturelles
parce qu'ils ne peuvent plus fonctionner
facilement reste parce qu'ils peuvent
fonctionner plus facilement pardon en
respectant des règles sanitaires
les médiathèques les bibliothèques les
petits musées
si important pour la vie culturelle de
nos territoires pourront rouvrir leurs
portes dès le 11 mai
a contrario les grands musées qui attire
un grand nombre de visiteurs hors de
leur bassin de vie
les cinémas les théâtres et les salles
de concerts où l'on reste à la même
place dans un milieu fermé ne pourront
pas rouvrir les salles des fêtes les
salles polyvalentes resteront également
fermée jusque à cette marche du 2 juin
pour donner aux organisateurs
d'événements de la visibilité
je veux préciser que les grandes
manifestations sportives culturelles
notamment les festivals les grands
salons professionnels tous les
événements qui regroupe plus de 5000
participants et font à ce titre l'objet
d'une déclaration en préfecture et qui
doivent être organisées longtemps la
vence ne pourront se tenir avant le mois
de septembre la saison 2019-2020 de
sport professionnel notamment celle de
football ne pourra pas non plus
reprendre
quant aux lieux de culte jeu c'est
l'impatience des communautés religieuses
les lieux de culte pourront continuer à
rester ouverts mais je crois qu'il est
légitime de demander de ne pas organiser
de cérémonie
avant cette barrière du 2 juin les
cérémonies funéraires resteront
évidemment autorisé comme aujourd'hui
dans la limite de 20 personnes j'ai
parfaitement conscience de la charge et
de la difficulté face à des décès
d'appliquer
cette règle mais elle est formulée en
france comme dans d'autres pays
comparables
afin là encore de protéger les vivres
les cimetières seront à nouveau ouverts
au public dès le 11 mai en attendant des
jours meilleurs les mairies continuerons
à proposer sauf urgence le report des
mariages d'une façon générale il nous
faut éviter les rassemblements qui sont
autant d'occasions de propagation du
virus
les rassemblements organisés sur la voie
publique ou dans des lieux privés seront
donc limitées à 10 personnes
l'oms et messieurs ces règles de vie
sociale peuvent paraître compliqué elles
sembleront sans doute sévère à certains
est peut-être trop laxiste à d'autres au
fond ce que je vous propose de rétablir
c'est un régime de liberté dans lequel
nous devons fixer des exceptions
ces règles sont contraignantes c'est
vrai mais je crois pouvoir compter sur
le civisme de nos compatriotes pour que
chacun les appliquent avec rigueur
il en va de notre santé à tous nous
avons certainement dans ces domaines
oublié des points formulé de façon à
certaines des règles omis de prévoir
dentelle ou territoire une adaptation
possible
c'est tout l'intérêt de la phase qui
s'ouvre il s'agit d'enrichir ce plan
tous ensemble avec les élus avec les
administrations terrain avec les
partenaires sociaux avec tous les
français pour être prêt le 11 mai ces
efforts ne sont pas vains et nous
permettront je l'espère de façon très
concrète d'envisager la période estivale
sous de meilleurs auspices je donne
d'ores et déjà rendez vous aux français
à la fin du mois de mai pour évaluer les
conditions dans lesquelles nous
organiserons une nouvelle phase de
déconfinement et prendront en
particulier des décisions sur
l'organisation et la réouverture je les
dis des cafés des restaurants des
vacances il est trop tôt aujourd'hui en
conscience pour le faire
pour la suite la stratégie que je viens
de présenter l'architecturé générale de
ce plan de déconfinement approuvé en
conseil de défense sous la présidence du
chef de l'état n'est pas un texte
législatif
elle exigera des décisions
réglementaires ou individuelles prises
par les ministres ou les préfets ou par
les présidents d'exécutifs locaux dans
le champ de leurs compétences sur
quelques sujets néanmoins elle devra
être accompagnée de dispositions
législatives qui n'existe pas
aujourd'hui et qui vont manquer j'en
prends deux exemples pour tracer les
contacts pour remonter jusqu'à ce qu'ils
ont croisé le chemin d'un malade il
faudra sans doute faire appel à des
effectifs supplémentaires pour renforcer
les médecins quand je dis sans doute
c'est certain j'évoquais tout à l'heure
l'appui des personnes de l'assurance
maladie on pourrait sans doute dans ces
brigades
on pourra sans doute dans ces brigades
accueillir
parfois les personnels des crs des
mairies parfois peut-être des personnels
des départements parfois des personnels
mis à disposition par les grandes
associations je pense par exemple à la
croix rouge encore une fois c'est aux
équipes locales qu'il reviendra
d'organiser ces brigades
mais ce qui est certain c'est qu'ils ne
seront pas tous médecins il faudra donc
que la loi les autorise à participer à
ces enquêtes épidémiologiques dans
lesquelles l'accès à des données
médicalisé pourra être nécessaire
autre exemple la limitation des
déplacements entre régions ou entre
départements dans la période de
confinement il était possible de limiter
ses déplacements dans le cadre général
de la loi du 23 mars
ce ne sera plus possible une fois le
confinement levées si nous voulons
éviter que la circulation du virus ne
s'accélère dans des zones jusque là
préservées il nous faudra cette
possibilité de nous faudra limiter cette
possibilité de se déplacer au moins dans
un premier temps sur ces deux sujets et
sur quelques autres
il conviendra donc de légiférer
je proposerai au parlement d'adopter
prochainement une loi qui en plus de
projets l'état d'urgence sanitaire
au delà du 23 mai peut-être jusqu'au 23
juillet autorisera la mise en oeuvre des
mesures nécessaires à l'accompagnement
du déconfinement ce projet sera soumis à
l'examen du conseil des ministres samedi
prochain et sera soumis au sénat et à
l'assemblée nationale la semaine
prochaine pour exposer cette stratégie
nationale le gouvernement a choisi
d'avoir recours aux dispositions de
l'article 50-1 de la constitution
rien dans la constitution n'impose est
au gouvernement de présenter à
l'assemblée nationale la stratégie que
je viens d'exposer
on peut le déplorer on devrait
d'ailleurs se dire qu'il faudra demain
peut-être corriger ce défaut mais nos
institutions sont ainsi fait il aurait
été pour le gouvernement possible de
procéder à cette présentation au cours
d'un journal télévisé au cours d'une
conférence de presse
et reconnaissons que cela s'est déjà
fait de très nombreuses fois et sous
tous les gouvernements de la vème
république
nous avons choisi de réserver à
l'assemblée nationale ces annonces et au
delà de ces annonces la capacité
et au delà de ces annonces la capacité
de réagir de critiquer bien sûr
d'interroger aussi le gouvernement sur
ce plan qui comme je lé déjà indiqué à
vocation être complétée par les
autorités locales les organisations
syndicales et patronales
enfin la possibilité par le vote pour
chaque député de dire sa position sur la
stratégie que je viens d'exposer ce
choix repose sur plusieurs raisons
d'abord la place évidemment éminente de
cette assemblée dans notre démocratie
inutile d'en dire beaucoup sur une
conviction que nous partageons tous en
ces temps de démocratie médiatique de
réseau pas très sociaux mais très
colérique d'immédiateté nerveuse il est
sans aucun doute utile de rappeler que
les représentants du peuple siège
délibère et se prononce sur toutes les
questions d'intérêt national
je souligne
je soulignais ce faisant je considère
évidemment qu'il n'y a là que
l'expression d'un devoir et en aucune
façon celui d'une faveur que le
gouvernement que j'ai l'honneur de
diriger a systématiquement est
évidemment répondu présent à toutes les
demandes de dire de députés de leur
commission sur la crise que nous
connaissons la mission d'information les
commissions permanentes les questions au
gouvernement pendant le confinement tout
cela a continué et c'est tant mieux car
le gouvernement en avait besoin
comme nous nous y sommes engagés nous
communiquons toutes les semaines à
l'assemblée et au sénat
l'ensemble des décisions qui sont prises
dans le cadre de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire y compris celles qui ne relève
en rien du domaine législatif face aux
décisions que nous avions à prendre et
que nous aurons encore à prendre le
contrôle du parlement n'est pas un poids
c'est une chance dire ici ceux que je
viens de dire plutôt qu'ailleurs répond
à la volonté du gouvernement de montrer
qu'en dépit de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire en dépit des difficultés
évidentes à exercer ses mandats dans une
période de confinement la démocratie
parlementaire reste vivante exigeante
parfois bruyante mais indispensable
toujours la seconde raison et qui nous
apparaît nécessaire de permettre à
chaque député qu'il soit présent dans
l'hémicycle ou qu'ils suivent les débats
à distance de se prononcer sur cette
stratégie de dire s'ils l'approuvent et
la soutient de dire s'il la conteste et
la rejette ou de dire s'il s'abstient
mais de prendre position en
responsabilité comme il revient
représentants de la nation qui ne
peuvent pas qu'ils ne veulent pas et qui
ne doivent pas être relégués au rang de
commentateurs de la vie politique
j'ai été frappée mesdames et messieurs
les députés depuis le début de cette
crise par le nombre de commentateurs
ayant une vision parfaitement claire de
ce qu'il aurait fallu faire selon eux à
chaque instant
la modernité les a souvent fait passer
du café du commerce à certains plateaux
de télévision les courbes d'audience y
gagne ce que la convivialité des
bistrots hyper et je ne crois pas que
cela grandissent le débat public
non les députés ne commente pas ils
votent et ce faisant ils prennent des
positions politiques
c'est votre honneur c'est votre mission
et c'est ce que je vous invite à faire
après le débat qui suivra cette
déclaration mesdames et messieurs les
députés
la france est dans 20 de ces moments où
ce qu'il est mais la serbe doivent être
à la hauteur
nous devons protéger les français sans
immobiliser la france au point qu'elle
s'effondrerait c'est une ligne de crête
délicate qu'il nous faut suivre un peu
trop d'insouciance et c'est l'épidémie
qui repart un peu trop de prudence et
c'est l'ensemble du pays qui s'enfonce
la stratégie que je viens d'énoncer a
pour objet de nous permettre de tenir
cette ligne de crête
elle repose sur des choix que je viens
de présenter
il repose sur l'action déterminée du
gouvernement et de l'état sous
l'autorité du président de république
elle repose sur la confiance que nous
plaçons dans les collectivités
territoriales dans les acteurs du monde
économique et sociale dans les
associations elles reposent aussi est au
fond avant tout sur les français sur nos
concitoyens sur leur civisme et leur
discipline
aucun plan aucune mesure aussi
ambitieuse soit elles ne permettront
d'endiguer cette épidémie si les
français n'y croient pas ou ne les
appliquent pas si la chaîne virale et
par remplacer par une chaîne de
solidarité à partir du 11 mai le succès
ne reposera pas sur la seule autorité de
l'état
mais sur le civisme des français en
juillet 2010 est dans des circonstances
bien différentes mais à cette même
tribune à l'occasion de la première
déclaration de politique générale
j'avais évoqué cette antique qualité
dans laquelle les romains puiser leurs
forces
la vertu celle qui mêle
rectitude honnêteté et courage j'étais
loin d'imaginer alors combien cette
qualité threat essentiel dans les
semaines à venir pour préparer notre
avenir l'avenir de nos enfants l'avenir
de la france je vous remercie
j'ai lu ça
merci monsieur le premier ministre la
séance est suspendue pour 15 minutes